(chant de voctoire)
- Une arrivée du Qarar
en pleine nuit.
L'avion des lignes aériennes
argentines qui proclame :
"une équipe, upapays, un rêve".
Le porteur du rêve,
c'est Lionel Messi, 35 ans,
désormais dieu du football
mondial.
(acclamations)
Accueilli au son de "Muchachos",
l'hymne de l'équipe depuis
sa victoire sur le Brésil
en Copa América l'an dernier.
♪ ♪ ♪OnOnOn en a changé les pare
"nous voulons être champions du
monde" à "maintenant nous sommes
champions du monde; il ne nous
reste qu'à faire la fête".
♪ ♪ ♪
L'autobus à impériale
a conduit les joueurs au centre
d'entraînement, tout proche,
de la Fédération argentine
de football pour se reposer,
sous les acclamations
de milliers de supporteurs.
Un cordon policier les tenait
à l'écart des joueurs pendant
leur repos, sous ll l l vigilant
de "gauchos", autre emblème
du pays.
Lionel Messi a publié ces photos
de sa courte nuit avec la coupe.
Suivi du porro de maté,
indispensable à un Argentin.
(applaudissements)
Pour les supporteurs par contre,
pas question d'interrompre
la nuit blanche : il fallait
assister à la lente remontée
de l'autobus vers le centre
de Buenos Aires.
- (foule): Argentina! Argentina!
On estime que 4 millions
de personnes se sont rassemblées
près de l'obélisque de la place
de la République par cette
chaude journée de congé
avant les Fêtes et leseseseses
vacances de l'été austral.
En attendant leurs héros,
il leur a fallu tuer le temps,
se nourrir au pa
d'un petit choripan, mais
en vain parce que le convoi
des champions du monde
n'avançait plus dans la foule
compacte.
Partis vers midi, ils n'avaient,
trois heures plus tard, parcouru
qu'une dizaine des 32 kilomètres
qui les sé d d d d de l'avenue
du 9 juillet.
Ils ont dû renoncer et
la Fédération de football
s'est excusée auprès du public
de noioioioioir pu continuer en
raison, dit-elle, de l'explosion
de joie populaire.
"Continuons de célébrer en paix
et de leur montrer notre amour
et admiration."
C'est donc en hélicoptère
que la sélrgrgrgrgrgentine a
survolé tout le parcours prévu.
Les champions du monde n'iront
pas, semble-t-il, comme c'était
laàààààà la présidence,
la Casa Rosada, rencontrer
les dirigeants du pays.
Jean-Michel Leprince,